millions of people were touched when
they saw your first Instagram the moment
before you shaved your head and this was
just that moment rare you know my mom
was comforting me and and I was crying
after my second treatment my hair was
really matted like a dreadlocks and I
went to try to brush it out and it just
fell out and it was just his room I'm
holding on to like just huge clumps of
my hair and my hands and just running to
my mom and crying being like my hair and
my hair my hair my hair and and it was
just shedding and it was driving me
crazy and it was just I mean clumps and
and and I was like just grab the kitchen
scissors just a graphic kitchen and my
mom's like wait wait wait I'm just
grabbing so she went and she grabbed the
kitchen scissors I put it in a ponytail
and she just chopped it up okay
and it was this cute little bob but it
wasn't enough you know it was just
falling out and then you shaved into a
mohawk so we did stages we did a pixie
and then we did a mohawk which was my
favorite looks and then it finally and
then we finally had to get the the
shaver thing and and just buzz it off I
just I didn't want somebody to take a
picture of me coming out of the grocery
store and be like Oh God look at her I
wanted to put it out there the way that
it felt the best for me to put it out
there and also if I could help one
person then it makes me go oh okay I
it's easier to live with having cancer
if I know I'm helping at least one
person